welcome yellow good folks hi I'm Eric
singer Eric is still spending his days
being a dialect coach for film and
television today we're gonna be going
through some different portrayals of
presidents I were a suit for the
occasion John F Kennedy James Marsden
the butler the fires a discord are
burning in every city north and south
where legal remedies are not at hand I
think that taking on JFK is a thankless
task
for an actor it's a case of damned if
you do damned if you don't because if
you go for a really perfect kind of
uncanny impersonation of that famous
famous famous voice burning in every
city the fires are discord or burning in
every city New Orleans no how you better
get it absolutely right otherwise
something's gonna be a little jarring
where legal remedies are not at hand
where legal remedies so some of the
famous bowel sounds are there some of
the cadences know you son is the freedom
writer great change is it a great cage I
don't think much of an attempt was made
to find Kennedy's vocal quality giving
all Americans the right to be served in
facilities which are open to the public
giving all Americans the right to be
served in facilities but even if you're
not going for very much I think there's
some basic things that really kind of
have to be included Kennedy was a
non-rhotic speaker he didn't pronounce
ours after vowel sounds almost at all
weapons of war
the threat of war not because they are
easy but because they are hard as all
Panther Marston ends up putting quite a
few in sometimes they're light sometimes
they're a little more pronounced but you
can hear some of them here over the next
four years for the past to me is changed
his heart heart of course is a word that
shouldn't have an R in it if you're a
candidate but in addition to that the
vowel that comes before the R sound
which is a back vowel for me tongue is
low in the back ah heart for Kennedy of
course is front vowel part of the
question II changed his heart and I
think that again is such an incredibly
famous iconic part of this accent I
think it's really hard to be kennedy
without it here's Marsden the thigh is a
discord or burning in every city north
and south
and here's Kennedy the fires of discord
of burning in every city north and south
Don F Kennedy Greg Kinnear the Kennedys
the energy the faith the devotion
control he like I think he threads the
needle here I think this is successful
and it's hard to to candidate you know
there's something really interesting I
talk a lot about oral posture there's
something really interesting about
hesitation sounds thinking sounds
that'll be something that we will love
your mouth is gonna go to an easy place
a comfortable place so that it can get
to whatever the next sound happens to
happens to end up being listen to
Kinnear doing a John F Kennedy
hesitation sound here III I think I know
how many of you feel my he nails it
that's what Kennedy sounded like listen
I am a strong believer in equal pay for
equal work and I think that we oughta
work we I think that day that'll be
something that we will love so I thought
that it really would be yet work to well
and there's something so valuable about
getting that if you can get that shape
and feel in your mouth everything else
becomes easier george w bush josh brolin
w we can get one democracy going in one
of these places iran iraq believe me
Reagan was right it's gonna spread to
all these countries I think this is
really amazing we're all proud of you
let's talk about world posture have a
look at the way those lip corners are
pulled back the lips are kind of pressed
in tightly of course there's that squint
there's something that feels like it's
set in a kind of resolution right it's a
certainty it's the I'm the decider I'm
the decider and he's listening through
that posture the oral posture is
entirely in place and I think it
crystallizes something about the
internal life of the character about a
decision that that character has made at
some point about how he wants to appear
it's just right thank you for their
George W Bush Connor tree near American
made your pilot
I've been known to flash huh me too
Air National are 68-69 it's so good
there's so many really great details
from a kind of the way that he's looking
up from you know a lowered head well to
the smoothed out price valves and pilot
pilot 969 to that kind of abruptness
that you know I'm the designer thing I'm
the decider me to beauty to that hard
Bray star and Guard Air National Park ha
it's really really good
see you around flat boy george w bush
will ferrell SNL and elsewhere I believe
itself his figures may be inaccurate
don't mess with Texas this is one that
definitely got a lot better over time
here's much more recently I had : ed
Conde don't forget about my good friends
Alberto Gonzales a lot more specific lot
more finely observed one thing I'd like
to point out look at this no use crying
about it apparently it's what the
American people want you can see almost
the same oral posture as in Josh Brolin
here doubted I won the election my
judgment it's those pulled back lip
corners right and those tightly held
lips well Gladys it's that jaw that's
just a little bit thrust forward so it's
really interesting I think Will
Ferrell's a talented impressionist so
even though it's slightly exaggerated we
see some very very fine observations
just like we do in a much more
straightforward and kind of uncanny a
vocation of w I don't know what that
means but I know it's positive Barack
Obama Devin Tyrell Barry and sometimes I
feel like I want to breathe in
everything New York is awful
all the times it all seems like one big
distraction this is one of those
instances in which an actor makes a
choice to evoke somehow the famous voice
that we are really familiar with
political distraction big distraction
without going for some kind of uncanny
impression yeah thanks because he's
playing a younger Obama an Obama before
we knew him I'm supposed to speak on
behalf of all black people for a lot of
kids the doors that have been open to me
aren't open to them so when he ends up
settling on are a handful of prasat ik
features to do with rhythm
intonation and you can really hear that
kind of evoking Obama here for instance
parents are married five times between
them or six and I'm not even sure about
my father
good morning well this is not how I
expected to wake up this morning just a
footnote here this is extra impressive I
think what's so special about me because
Devin Tyrells Australia I'm right-handed
so I have to learn how to play possible
that tending the right left-handed the
accent that's pretty good I didn't know
you could do me Barack Obama
Parker Sawyer's South Side with you it's
not easy to get things done the founders
made it that way on purpose so that no
one law no one government no one man
could decide the fate of everything and
everyone Sawyer's is also playing in
Young Obama and he makes a similar
choice except in his case I think it's
even a little bit further away it's even
a little bit more just evocative it's
hoping you wouldn't notice again the
choice seems to mostly be to focus on
Obama's rhythm and prose adido in the
folks downtown he had Hispanic folks we
got some good folks and you got Asian
folks we've got some good harder folks
they need folks folks there's something
about the way he cuts things off right
at the end of a phrase sort of lets you
know that it's final and he's moving on
to the next thing you can hear that
really well here in it wasn't an option
wasn't an option the first stops wasn't
an option it's just closing you know we
got a heck of a lot of different people
all of you are the backbone they are few
and far between we have to move forward
Barack Obama Jay Pharoah Saturday Night
Live you better bring your Mormon magic
Underpants and your wife's dancing horse
cuz bladder would I play up late for
kicks
okay so this is a comedy impression it
has a different purpose so it's coming
from a different place oh really oh man
it's always still built on certain
accurate observations it's just you
usually you pick one or two or three and
then you kind of turn the dial up on
them desperate times call for desperate
measures and if it's good comedy
impression you're kind of making some
sort of point with it nonetheless in
this case I think farro is really really
really fixated on and turning the dial
up on some of those same prasat ik
features
it's that fall American pepper it's that
very clip thing coming here he does that
a lot
nothing is getting through we can hear
that characteristic fall here in I don't
know why more offices aren't oval I
don't know why uh more offices
Arnaudville FDR Bill Murray Hyde Park on
Hudson no one ever mentions the fact
that I can't use my legs it's never
breathe don't do so he's dropping his
arse after vowel sounds please don't do
power to power I feel like a lot of it
really just isn't there though I want to
apologize his very dark L sounds with a
bunched back of the tongue my legs legs
as opposed to FDR's light ones your
children later legs later legs those
vowel sounds and words like honest
honest honest
not-not-not
need to have a little bit of lip
rounding because because to get FDR
let's change the subject shall we let's
look at three different comedians
versions of Trump now we're gonna look
at taran killam is Trump Darryl Hammonds
Trump and Jimmy Fallon's Trump here's
ten killin as the man who's almost
certainly your next president I wanted
to give you a chance to get to know the
real Donald
here's Darrell Hammond debates are
stupid you should be paying me and Wolf
Blitzer looks like Papa Smurf
here's Palin first of all you're all
fake news ain't you all very much and
thank you for being you feel like taran
killam is zeroed in most on oral posture
especially those lip shapes it's huge
huge huge problem in China somebody from
China they're really really really
exaggerated but that's kind of the thing
he's hanging his impression on have a
look again just
biggest right thank you doh thank you
darling I got the smartest guys but we
have people that are stupid stupid I'm
just like you but better Daryl heavens
doing a lot I think he's got some of
that posture it's a little subtler yep
you're a very nice man but you're
basically a little girl he's really
focusing in though I think on the rhythm
and inflection the way a sort of Trump
will kind of draw a thing out and will
possibly get a bad ruling and then drop
it down and we will have a national
emergency
draw a thing out and drop it down you
can listen to that here I'm at 43 and we
will then be sued and you're at 3 in the
Ninth Circuit yep you're a nice guy
shouldn't be there you're a lightweight
where's I think Fallon is really focused
on trying to get the vocal quality right
listen to that again we've made so much
progress in fact if you ask any American
don't say that I've managed to make the
last four weeks feel like for years the
extraordinary progress so much progress
progress winning big li big big league
big league Piggly Wiggly giggly big
leagues for a subtler more
multi-dimensional more accurate
integrated and authentic version of
Trump the human being I think we may
have to wait a while George HW Bush
James Cromwell W what are you cut out
for party chasing tail driving drunk
what do you think you are a Kennedy
James Cromwell said something really
interesting about his performance in
this he said I came to the set hidden
behind my own characterization and
Oliver attacked it he made me go right
to the Father and not to my caricature
of Bush as an actor you can't condescend
to a character it's critical I make the
right call if you have a judgment about
who that person is from the outside you
can't really effectively play them
inauthentic and I think that's what
Oliver Stone was telling James Cromwell
here I came to the set hidden behind my
own characterization and Oliver attacked
it and so when Oliver Stone said you
can't play the judgment you have to play
the person whose decision to make I bet
that that impression had to go away with
that judgment we all make mistakes and
we're ending up with something that
evokes him very lightly and some of the
rhythms and things like that
here's Cromwell our family the Bush
family we honor our
and here's the real-life George HW Bush
and I feel so dedicated and strongly
about it that I just wanted to wedge
that in so it's reminiscent and it
evokes it but more importantly I think
that choice allowed James Cromwell to
focus on playing a real round full
three-dimensional person which is what's
important appreciate your support
Bill Clinton Dennis Quaid the special
relationship don't be surprised if you
feel completely totally overwhelmed when
you do get into office this is
surprisingly good too good to be true
he has that sort of Clinton hoarseness
consider our military options discuss
the military options
but it's not just hoarseness there's
actually a kind of a pressed down
quality in the larynx we all just got a
chill little Joey gets to which a lot of
people don't when they're doing Clinton
not on my watch one of the vowel sounds
are right you can listen to that goose
fowl that is fronted here right thing to
do right thing to do with you and that
very Arkansas o goat vowel here Global
global NATO NATO NATO they told a lot of
good details of smart call Bill Clinton
ish John Travolta primary colors I don't
have to tell you how hard it is to be
looking for work hey I don't have to
tell you anything about hard times so I
think the choice here was probably just
to suggest Clinton hmm there are some
things that are there very strongly that
horse vocal quality again probably the
most famous thing about Clinton
absolutely I am really happy to be here
absolutely he does a pretty good job
targeting this specifically it's got
that kind of press down feel as well
just right I do think he's relying on
that vocal quality to do most of the
work there are a lot of accent things
that aren't really in place this is bad
Travolta is fleece and goose vowels the
vowel sounds and words like me and two
just don't sound southern at all me too
- me too - and I've talked a lot about
the goose fronting the arts of the
tongue being further forward in the
mouth ooh
goose yes we do so you know what I'm
gonna do do do do not an exact match
make it look like I'm gonna hammer talk
Lyndon Baines Johnson
Bryan Cranston all the way now we're
making history here Everett and you have
to decide how you want his
to remember you and I think this is
amazing it's so deep in and so
particularly observed or somebody who
just likes to hear himself Koch Johnson
had a very bunched up back of his tongue
Koch oh oh oh
it's bunched and pulled back and so the
tip of the tongue as in most Texas
accents has to sort of curl up a little
further and that means that when the
tongue tip needs to touch like on a D
sound shed or get close like on an
s-sound blade it's not gonna make
contact in exactly the same place as it
might in a different American accent
what happens when the Ness sound is it's
further away from that gum Ridge so we
got Russell O'Neill exceed come on which
is lower pitched then special brush
color color
I call it hypo sibilant Shh you can hear
that here mr. skin started started
started and in Johnson members of the
Congress Congress started started
Congress in that cool oh hum freakin
know George Washington Jeff Daniels the
Crossing we became a nation on the 4th
of July six months ago we held our three
largest cities Boston New York and
Philadelphia I don't think there's a ton
here to talk about in terms of vocal and
speech choices what do you think I do
think he's he's bumped up his formality
a little bit would you specify there's a
kind of a precision of articulation and
final consonants that communicates
something that's formal yes superiority
will be their undoing think this kind of
makes sense for Washington we know it
cared a lot about manners thought they
were essential welcome sir
have you eaten and we do have some
reports from contemporaries of
Washington about what his voice sounded
like it is late but perhaps not too late
so I think there's more that you might
be able to do here have you finished
FDR Jon Voight Pearl Harbor yesterday
December 7th 1941 a date which will live
in infamy so he doesn't really do that
singing through the line that sort of
sustained intonation that you can hear
an FDR here a date which will live in
infamy a day
which will live in infamy at the same
time a lot of the accent and that sort
of very firm present vocal presence are
really there to overcome this
premeditated invasion overcome this
premeditated invasion so if I could have
adjusted one thing in his oral posture
here I would have loved to see a little
bit of FDR's jaw protrusion his jaws a
little bit forward and for me that
communicates something about it's kind
of representative of his patrician
background and even his gravitas I think
it might have added something we have to
do more George Washington Jon Voigt an
American Carol when you meet the
almighty Michael only the truth will do
I think I like his FDR better I feel
like this is a little bit one dimension
is that what you're going to say on
judgement day it's like the character is
serving a very simple function in the
story he's just there to be patriotic
I'm here to talk to you about freedom
and have gravitas and remind you of the
seriousness of purpose of all of that
ready for guidance and leading this
nation it's kind of like the vocal
delivery mirrors that without doing much
else I'm afraid that won't do George
Washington David Morse John Adams I do
not think myself equal to the command I
am honored with I think it's really
clear some research went into this you
don't have any video or audio of George
Washington speaking we do have
descriptions from contemporaries of his
that say that he actually had a
surprisingly soft and even high voice
independence from one end of the
colonies to the owner and also that he
tended to keep his mouth closed of
course he famously had terrible terrible
teeth and when you have terrible teeth
and no dentistry a very bad breath
forgive me so that makes a lot of sense
I think we can see and hear those things
in David Morse's performance have a look
at this here I George Washington do
solemnly swear
[Music]
it's a really interesting contrast to
Washington was a very tall man of
absolutely commanding presence and yet
to have a kind of just a soft-spoken
voice go along with that I think is
fascinating and apparently that's what
the guy was actually like David Morse is
really doing that so I don't be God
Theodore Roosevelt Brian Geraghty the
alienist even if I wanted to I cannot
allow you access to the body as it's
still in police custody let's listen to
a little bit of Teddy Roosevelt are the
American people fit to govern themselves
to rule themselves to control them I
believe
so here's Garrity as Roosevelt are you
suggesting you should be allowed to
conduct a parallel investigation now the
actor didn't have a lot of time to
prepare before he filmed this I still
wish there was more of an attempt to go
towards that kind of singsong intonation
the fight would not be made at all and
though clipped off endings there's a
matter of it that is a Teddy Roosevelt
was a non-rhotic speaker he didn't
pronounce our sounds after vowel sounds
you can hear that here whereas Garrety
pronounces the R's a lot in words like
determined or Robert you can hear that
that will be determined determined by
the coroner Robert Robert also Teddy
Roosevelt had very lip read at vowel
sounds on all thought vowels Oh Oh what
I've gone well ooh
goose bells to make that B who wanted to
go to two very strongly loop around it
very strongly defined its accent for me
it sounds contemporary it not only
doesn't conjure up the time and the
place
it actually takes me out of the time in
the place a bit
John F Kennedy Michael C Hall the crown
it is time for a renewal a new
generation of leadership so Michael C
Hall is a really talented accent
performer what are me a rum and coke
I'll be there in ten I think he's one of
the few Americans we can see in a
high-profile show doing an English
accent and doing it pretty well in safe
Jenna its dad again here I'm not sure he
quite has it again I think he falls into
the Kennedy trap sorry and trying to put
my finger on it I think a lot of it
actually has to do with physical tension
the quality of opportunity so many great
opportunity Kennedy we now know was in a
lot of pain all the time I think we can
see that in Michael C Hall's performance
I look forward to a full report but it
goes along with a real stiffness he's
kind of hyper extending his neck and
there's a lot of tension in the face and
around the lips and John F Kennedy maybe
because he worked really hard at it
didn't seem to have that he seemed to
have a kind of an ease an easy grace and
style it is time for a new generation of
leadership have a look at Michael C Hall
here and especially in the line we
cannot go it alone you can see all that
tension and work we cannot do it alone
whereas here's Kennedy look at the ease
give me your help and your boy Gerald
Ford Chevy Chase Saturday Night Live the
pay off bill now before the House of
Representatives does not address the
current situation and I would veto it
this is one of my very favorite
impressions of all time but he's smart
it's not an impression he's doing
literally nothing Joey he's just using
physical comedy
to make the point that Ford was clumsy I
guess not that intelligent yellow I'm
girl bored and you're not doing nothing
else there's something absurd about it
alright hello no I don't know it just
makes me giggle thank you Abraham
Lincoln Kris Kristofferson tad
that's cheap Snow's Apple can't say had
one since New Salem days feller sent me
a barrel of yesterday I don't think
there's any real voice or accent work
taking place here I believe it is I
think Kris Kristofferson is really just
doing himself out there you have a sound
argument what are the interesting things
about Lincoln of course we don't have
any audio recordings but we have
descriptions from contemporaries and
they describe them as having had a
surprisingly high and sort of even Reedy
voice which is a fascinating contrast
with the sort of the gravitas and the
seriousness of the pictures that we have
in the image that we have of this guy
God knows most of us our carriage at
some time or another Abraham Lincoln
Gilbert Gottfried a million ways to die
in the West hiya shmucks four score and
seven years ago I once broke just like
you it's perfect Dwight the Eisenhower
Robert Duvall hike now there are still
French battleships RN Casablanca and
Algiers
I think Duvall has a kind of a a
staccato delivery that's very forceful
thing communicates something very
no-nonsense
a year eight years and Algiers years
listen to that staccato delivery and
we're planning to land in Algeria and
Morocco you're planning to land in
Algeria and Morocco where's I think the
real eisenhower had some of that kind of
punch but it was also counter poised
against a sort of a flow and ease you
can hear that here we must find some way
we need to gain an eternal peace for
this world Ronald Reagan Alan Rickman
the butler if Congress passes sanctions
against South Africa I will be forced to
veto those sanctions
rythms the Great Communicator Ronald
Reagan
I know how to hold the floor he knew how
to hold his audience's attention just to
show you how youthful I am I intend to
campaign in all 13 states there's a kind
of a trick it came incredibly naturally
to him which was he would finish one
sentence and then start the next
sentence straight away I will not make
age an issue of this campaign I am NOT
going to exploit and then he would pause
for political purposes my opponents
youth and inexperience gathering for
thought there's a taking of breath I can
still remember my first Republican
convention so it involves the whole
being Abraham Lincoln giving a speech
that and you can hear Alan Rickman doing
this as Reagan right here in this scene
if Congress passes this bill I will veto
it listen to the way he splits up for
thoughts here when he says my staff has
been trying to get me to a nice staff
who's been trying to get me to stop you
think you could help me I think you
could help me to write the pauses the
breaks don't come at the end of the
sentence they come in the middle of the
thought so it almost brings you forward
in anticipation listen it reminds me of
a story I in case you were wondering
this is my way of sliding into a story I
think a lot of what Alan Rickman's doing
for Reagan here is pinned on this one
thing I think it's incredibly successful
though our procedure over this Ronald
Reagan Tim Matheson killing Reagan tell
them of your support for this bipartisan
proposal tell them you believe this is
an unequalled opportunity to make
government again the servant of the
people so I think this is another
performance where the actors may be over
relying a little bit on just a vocal
quality and trying to let that do all
the work to him a lot of vowel sounds
that really aren't working right is
about in out I would like to walk back
down his vowel in you you you are very
much his own goose and mouth bowels and
very different from Reagan's versions of
those vowels locked out back locked out
back you you what are you you feels a
little bit like a missed opportunity
about conclusion so I just have a final
thought you might have noticed as we
went
some of these there's been a change
movies and TV shows that were done a
couple of decades ago tended not to put
much attention on the voice and speech
work the actors didn't even necessarily
try and that's really changed so I think
it's a really really really good thing
that this is something we're paying more
attention to I think we can do more but
the direction is right
[Music]
hi it's Eric singer again from on
location in Budapest Hungary if you love
technique critique you can get an early
look at some of the next episodes in our
series where in addition to me talking
about accents and idiolect you can hear
other experts looking at medicine law
and spy craft in movies and TV all you
have to do is download wired on your
streaming device now
[Music]